[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je garde beaucoup parce que j'ai appris
beaucoup rentrent le temps ça a été une
expérience super franchement je ne
redoute pas dépensier et j'ai retenu que
en fait que jamais lâcher parce que il
faut avec le travail et c'est du soin
cdu ans et plus on travaille plus on la
fois d'une bonne place et quand les
chèques nous avons fait tout ce que j'ai
appris c'est que je garde de cette
compétition
j'ai fait une très belle course à la
dernière étape je les bats lui tout seul
je lui avais découvert mois ils ont
travaillé pour moi désolé ou bien
suffire j'aimerais six derniers dixièmes
pour une poignée entourage quant à
benoît jacquot d'emma daumas une action
aussi et je ramasse les aux cannois qui
nous ont permis de participer à ses
frais à son propos